my death for you kiss it down oh hey you
know what I was just doing I was looking
at palm reading
it's really just something that I do not
get like are these people actual
credible sources or is it all just a
scam you know who does know about this
though my mystic guru curly curly can
you tell me about palm read yeah well
it's a really really really old
tradition I think that you go a lot from
looking at the lines I just I'm so
skeptical you know what I mean I think
you should be but you also should be
open in order for the energies work good
luck my friend thank you
so curly had some pretty interesting
things to say but I feel like I still
have to test this out for myself
I'm gonna go visit some palm readers and
see what's up we're optimistic Dylan on
normal Ave in Hollywood which just feels
ironic to me okay it's like it right
there
I don't understand how the gays like oh
maybe should ranked on accuracy vibe and
overall bestest just this city bestest
and I'm gonna ask them about my love
life I'm kind of curious with my
boyfriend plans on locking it down in
time soon I'm gonna see what these palm
readers have to say about it is that mr.
optimistic villains wow that should not
look like a palm reading office
hi how are you nice to meet you
okay so I'm probably gonna ask a lot of
dumb question okay so how do these
things start awesome so palmistry um
it's actually read with both hands okay
we're gonna start with your dominant
hand your dominant hand are the things
you've brought into this world hasit
hand is all the traits that you are born
with it's actually free will fate so
let's start here there nomina hand
okay the first thing that I'm seeing
right now this is your lifeline I'm
seeing either a bumpy childhood as you
had a lot of responsibility that was
thrown on you okay because of whatever
you viewed early on is an indication of
pessimism being pessimistic you see at
least you have the potential for two
marriages just so far away think they're
right now it's you putting focusing on
career yeah is there anything you want
to ask I was going to ask about marriage
and then you said that there was room
for two marriages and I was like this is
just like suggestions right yeah like I
said not obviously not for sure it could
also just be a long-term partnership
that drifts off into something else you
covered a whole lot thank you so curious
you're curious about my thoughts on this
yeah Alan alright so what's our rubric
so the first one was accuracy I'm gonna
give him a 4 out of 5 he did say there's
a lot of stuff in my past that made me
grow up quickly and effective whom I am
and I think that's definitely accurate
so my parents did divorce when I was
young
um and even though I was only like 15 or
whatever I ended up like in the middle
and kind of playing this middle parent
specificity you getting good at saying
that word thanks practice 3 out of 5
general vibe I'm going 5 out of 5 he had
a great ball he had a great vibe he was
super nice he was not like a little
skeptic I'm not dealing with you it's
weird that we're like at an apartment
though right yes to work we're just at
an apartment building there's no sign so
hopefully we're not murder
hi I'm Lisa I'm Jordan Jordan Stein nice
to me I do you brought your hands yes I
brought my hands with me so are we going
to read the left or the right well you
came with a match set so we're gonna
look at a match set see this cross right
here hey that's called the mystic cross
okay you're highly intuitive because
you've got the fire heart when it comes
to love you have to have several places
where you're getting your fuel so you
can actually burn through people and
that's meant to happen all right if you
marry young you've got at least two
marriages and so you really do need to
take your time your best bet is to enjoy
being in partnership with whoever it is
until you're at least 35 years old did
you have specific questions I wanted it
I was gonna ask you if I was gonna get
married but now I'm nervous
see what you can do you can fade that
that second marriage line and get it
down to one that's good to know
you know don't be afraid to get married
don't be afraid to fall in love so we
just left Lisa's all right accuracy free
oh it was weird
they both said the thing about the two
marriages that was a little oh that was
weird
that is sappy specificity two out of my
butt as far as the vibe I'm going 5 out
of 5 it did feel more like a therapy
session but that's not a bad thing so
I've been thinking about this for a
couple days and going into it I thought
I was gonna be able to disprove
palm-reading by comparing and
contrasting different experiences but it
actually really surprised me
so mystic Dylan and Lisa both had some
similar things to say like how they both
see me having two marriages but I refuse
to let that be a thing because I'm just
too stubborn and opposing things like
how I prioritize love and career but it
was a little difficult to compare
because they're kind of hard to judge if
it's actually specific to me or just
broad enough that it will apply to most
people that's not to say I didn't like
it I did get a lot of good advice
I liked reflecting on what feels true to
me and I met a lot of interesting people
and it's kind of fun just having someone
talk about you for a half an hour so I'm
glad I tried my hand in it
stop it's that's a funny joke it's a
good pun it's a good point how did you
know